I'd like you to draw this diagram twice
because I'm going to do this question
twice and I'll show you what so enjoy
yourself this kind of upside down ll
shape draw me a pair of them and put all
of the measurements that they provide
you can put the ball
there is always ok now i know i know
people are not always fans android
diagrams which honestly makes me a bit
sad those diagrams are so awesome they
packed so much information into such a
small space I think you're kind of
kidding yourself to try and do these
questions accurately without diagrams so
if you draw them there I'm going to do
this two different ways and we're going
to give them names after we've done it
but if you have another color this would
be enormous news so the opposite area I
want to work out the area of this
l-shaped type object so here's method
number one what I'm going to do first is
I see that this we don't shave is kind
of made up of two rectangles that are
jammed together yeah now you can figure
out a couple of different ways but I'm
going to put a line here like so so I
have a wide rectangle at a tall
rectangle and in order to describe them
i want to give them names because
they're both rectangles i can save this
rectangle that rectangle so i'm going to
call this one are 14 rectangle one and
i'm going to call this one are two from
rectangle to you can need them anything
you might visit your names but i think
that way it's pretty unambiguous if you
have trailers you come to you want to do
etc what everyone so now that I've got
some areas there's again I'm just going
to wait them out one at a time so the
area of our one well what's the formula
for the area of a rectangle length has
bread right so i have a leg p that's 3
i'll write that down first I don't have
a breath that's been actually pull onto
the diagram for me so I kind of have to
work it out it's this distance here and
it's seven how did you work out that it
was seven
good so you've got this whole egg 10 and
you're taking away the three that gets
hold you down here right so 3573 by
sevens not hard so this is 21 square
centimeters and I'm going to rinse and
repeat for the second rectangle this
claim because of the way I've chopped it
up I actually do have a link the breadth
of rectangle too so i'm just going to
write three by 43o 14 i think is 50 4242
espresso beans okay so you've got all
your pieces this is a nice simple one to
begin with there's only two so I've done
now i'm going to say therefore the total
area equals that looks like 63 square
centimeters and you're done okay so this
is not complicated as you can see you
probably could have worked out this dull
are like directly with just one equation
but I'm going to say as you get two more
complicated shapes having be able to
break them up and go through them
systematically becomes more and more and
their teams too so that's how I did it
the first way we'll give that a name in
a minute go to the second instance that
you're drawing this Psalm rectangle I
begin going to put a dotted line here
but I'm going to do a different one I'm
going to crawl my dotted lines over here
on what okay so remember how we sent
over this is two rectangles that have
been added onto a jumper you can also
think of it as our big rectangle we're
in a smaller rectangle cut out of it
yeah so again if I can work out the big
one and then work out a small one then I
just find a dress so I'm going to call
the big one of our one is how I'm going
to she's insane labels again you could
call them anything you like you called
big R & bill r 1 and I'm gonna call this
one too okay what's the area of this
big rectangle yeah 100 point which of
course trucks from 10 x 14 so I'm just
going to pocket that away and when I
work out this smaller rectangle I've got
to do what I did before and say oh this
is seven what's this distance this is 14
take away three yeah so 11 so I'm going
to say seven times 11 that's 77 square
sin now importantly because I'm
combining these areas in different ways
I'm not going to add them like I did
over here i'm going to subtract them so
i'm going to do 140 take away 77 but
again because it's still the same shape
and you can confirm this on your
calculator you will still get a
sixty-three percent of it ok so let's
give these things some names here I was
adding up rectangles and here I was
subtracted rectangles so I like to call
this one by addition and I like to call
this one no prizes for guessing by
subtraction I will point out as well
depending on the shape that you have
right sometimes you can combine these
different methods let's just have a look
over here for example you have a look at
this one that's just a little bit TV oh
yeah stop live it up I'll have a look at
this shape for a second and think about
how you might slice your son how would
you go about doing it and remember
there's lots of different ways just like
I showed you over you there's lots of
different ways that are equally valid
which way will you choose ok so how
would I do it how would you like to do
it if I just said let's add things up
yeah ready what do you wanna suggest
something else
okay so how would you like me to slice
it up bye-bye you mean this one yep good
which they don't think you made this one
oh yes sorry sorry it's funny that it
looks okay okay is that what you meant
yeah so here you can work out right this
one be five by eight work out that is
what are we going to get here what's
this distance have a look careful looks
like 3 plus 9 yeah so that's 12 going
this way what's this distance yeah it's
10 plus 5 15 and you already know this
one is this is 10 by nine so doing this
a little bit quickly i guess i would say
the total area is equal to all right we
started with this guy 5 by 8 i'm going
to add this big one here which is what
is it again 12 5 15 and then i'm going
to subtract 10 butter and i don't know
what that's equal to but i'm pretty
confident that will give you the right
answer clearly you could divide up
different ways I mean just like we put
this vertical line in here you can put a
vertical line in here you could slice it
up whichever way you like the important
thing is you have something like this
like you've got multiple areas give them
names tell me which ones which don't
call them this rectangle and that
rectangle or the big rectangle and the
somewhat less big rectangle and don't
don't do that just give the leaves and
if you want to but then you have to
remember what shape John is and what
shapes TV is why not just only if you
say so um and then as well where you
combine them be careful and tell me the
way that you combine them someone in an
atom some innocent tracted actually tell
me what's going on okay